hey guys Justine and today is November
17th 2018 and it is the grand reopening
of the brand-new 3rd Street Atlas store
and this whole Street has such a special
place in my heart because this is the
first place that I ever came when I was
in Los Angeles and it's what made me
fall in love with this city it's what
made me move here and the fact that I'm
here again for the reopening of the
store is incredible I was here at the
original grand opening that happened in
2012 before that the store was located a
little bit further down on 3rd Street
and that's where opened in 2003 which
was great before the iPhone even came
out which is crazy to think that there
was a time for the iPhone
[Music]
I'm sorry
[Applause]
you are
[Music]
first open I was near dancing in a panda
onesie
I'm not gonna do that this year let's
never forget where we started
one of the things that you'll notice is
they now have a living wall and they
have these trees that are the same trees
that they have a park campus they are
called
let me read it too just to make sure I
don't mess the name of these trees up
they are triple trunk like history
[Music]
I've never seen retail quite like this
ironically the video monitor
it's amazing to make a monitor yeah 37
people why did they go then tall it's
like fifty or seventeen make it like the
biggest video well the United States
United States it's the same as the
biggest in China
[Music]
[Applause]
the field reversal on
sir means so much to me and I'm so glad
that you can be here and experience it
was me
[Music]